il ya un sujet en tous les cas qu'il ne
nous fera pas c'est la guerre d'irak
parce que je crois qu'on a des positions
assez assez proches tous les deux j'ai
lu quand même dans la presse quotidienne
régionale cette semaine des déclarations
que vous allez faites au sujet de la de
la guerre d'irak en disant c'est un
numéro de clown tragique et planétaire
oui quand en moi j'ai veillé jusqu'à 2
heures du matin pour regarder bush au
moment où les hostilités commençaient à
la télévision il a l'air vraiment d'un
petit chimpanzé avec des avec des yeux
pétillants d'une intelligence
à la mairie j'adore l'amérique je
connais mieux une certaine amérique que
bush sûrement il n'a pas lu un bouquin
c'est sûr il n'a pas lu john fante et il
n'a pas vu les films n'a pas vu les
films de cassavettes haleine et il a il
a pas et que je suis ici on lui parle de
gershwin micro atx une marque de jeans
donc je veux dire c'est terrible parce
que c'est
c'est en plus c'est un gangster il est
entouré de gangsters ils veulent le
pétrole pas pour l'amérique ils le
veulent pour eux et je suis pas pour ça
le meilleur ami de saddam hussein il
peut bien faire un chiche kebab
j'aurais été content mais vous avez
déclaré j'ai déclaré bilodeau
c'est la première guerre retard nasik
on veut du bien aux irakiens alors on
les tue oui on va pas dire autre chose
c'est quoi cette guerre s'est loupé de
toute façon parce que maintenant c'est
le bordel absolue et les hôpitaux sont
envahi l'on peut même plus opérer les
gens il n'ya qu'un monument qui est
gardée c'est le ministère du pétrole
samedi tous je veux dire c'est
extravagant cette histoire il faudrait
fermer sa gueule
moi je trouve très cool non formidable
que chirac est ouvert sa gueule
sauf que l'âge il me semble que
d'ailleurs depuis il a enfilé le
l'uniforme du général de gaulle et j'ai
peur qu'il perde son pantalon
et bien alors vous avez déclaré
vous avez déclaré guy bedos conclure
dans cet article l'est républicain c'est
une guerre fascistes ont vu ça c'est un
propos de repas oui en privé au risque
de déplaire à quelques intellectuels qui
sont atteints de syncope intellectuelle
et quand ils écrivent des articles dans
le monde
c'est pour ça que je fais du spectacle
moi j'avais vu un article dans le monde
récemment récemment ça fait quelques
temps oui un signe et c'est pas pour
dénoncer je suis pas une balance mais
avec jacky glucksmann est proposée film
voici dans ma double il
donc double peine à double peine la
porte est un personnage récurrent de
cette émission guy parce qu'il fait
partie des caves et les quatre mecs qui
sont prononcés pour la guerre
effectivement avec lux man bruckner et
alain madelin
ils sont quatre donc effectivement il
est souvent dans cette émission on est
ravi bonsoir groupe et je me suis trouvé
dans des combats avec maggie j'imagine
oui qu'on se mette bien d'accord ce soir
je suis mais on va essayer
[Musique]
et c'est la première fois que je passe à
cette émission
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on
m'a prévenue effectivement j'ai vu une
cassette d'une d'une émission qui a eu
lieu ici le 22 mars avec un mec qui se
prénomme romain goupil cinéaste
c'est un sosie avant ce mec a insulté
des invités insultes et laurent baffie
tu as tenu tête en disant à quenza il
lui a postillonner en disant qu'elle
parlait de ne savait pas d'où elles
parlaient qu'elle avait 14 ans que
c'était une petite conne qui traînait
dans le loft et qu'elle pouvait rien
savoir puisque le principe même but love
s'est on lit pas de journaux on regarde
pas la télé on regarde pas la seule à
l'actualité
il l'a insulté il a insulté baffie lui
répondant même pas aux questions et à
traiter de une horreur c'est bien la
chute la chute c'est que c'est un sosie
c'est pas moi moi je suis sur les
positions je suis sur les positions de
thierry sûreté position sur tes
positions je suis contre la guerre
d'ailleurs vous l'avez dit on n'a pas
trouvé d'armes de destruction massive
donc on aurait dû continuer on aurait dû
absolument continuer à envoyer les
inspecteurs on n'aurait rien trouvé
s'il n'y a pas d'argent mais si elles
sont donc dit qu'est ce qu'on aurait
fait on aurait levé l'embargo
on aurait permis à saddam de rester en
place d'avoir le free du pétrole de
nommer son fils et son autre fils après
lui 1 200 % dans encore un vote
extrêmement démocratique et on aurait eu
une nouvelle corée du nord mais c'est à
dire que grosso modo l'erreur qu'on fait
les américains et les anglo-américains
c'est de virer saddam hussein parce que
façon là dans l'europe non mais on a
doublement dans le cul parce que nous on
lui a vendu des arbres depuis 74 il ne
les a pas réglé
bon d'accord alors maintenant il faut
vite chez puis perles et tous les
américains nous disent vous pouvez vous
carrés dans le cube aux dettes
permet bien placé pour faire la morale à
tout le monde donc on va perdre l'argent
on perd les marchés puisqu'on n'a pas
participé de cet ingrédient choisi au
fait je suis moi je dit autre chose mon
cher romain là c'est le cas elle sait
que si les américains veulent tuer un
chef d'état comme ils l'ont fait avec
pinochet ou plutôt beau lapsus comme ils
l'ont fait avec parce que c'est un
dictateur biologique je me servais a
marqué ces aliens décès salvador allende
qui a été tué avec l'aide de la cia et
du fbi
il faut être très bien avoir ces dames
100 cents à assassiner les gosses et les
femmes et des vieillards
c'est sacré
[Applaudissements]
la même peine
si vous pouvez prendre position chez
vous un numéro va s'afficher c'est un
peu surpris les 40 la mine chez un peu
surtaxé mais bon vous tapez 1 si vous
êtes pour la guerre et 2 si vous êtes
contre l'abus scène c'est
la guerre contre l'iran la guerre
contrôle koweit la façon dont la
massacrer son propre peuple
lui c'est une arme de destruction
massive donc ces deux millions de morts
les deux millions de morts tu me les met
en balance avec quoi avec un moment pour
libérer ce peuple effectivement faut
essayer
celle avec le moindre incident on vous
délivre on nous la communauté
internationale nous mais bien sûr que
oui à la communauté internationale
l'amérique a fait la guerre tout seul
avec l'angleterre qui était le blaireau
de nouvelles âmes et la guerre sans la
france c'est tout la lamelle a garé sur
une coalition s'en sort la france et non
c'est une ronde de la manche démarre en
angleterre en ce pays des droits de
l'homme font sketch ces contrées bon là
un blème aventis et en espagne les trois
qui ont soutenu bouts pointus savent sur
quel moteur dans la manifester en
angleterre tu sais sur quoi sur pr
n'était fait pas la guerre tu sais ce
que ça veut dire ça prenait le thé fait
pas la guerre c'est à dire tu mets un
petit nuage de lait dans ta couche de
thé et tu regardes pas les massacres qui
a eu ce tu regardes pas tourner le banc
et tu regardes pas les le gazage des
kurdes réducteur rien tu assez réducteur
pour des mines à leurs éditeurs les
manifestations qui a eu à paris avec le
portrait de saddam hussein
c'est réducteur la station 8,4 oui c'est
ça c'est des dérapages que je n'approuve
pas du tout mais je tape au fort ne
l'avons pas d'aller en manifestation de
jany le pen en passant par vaillant en
passant par la droite et les cheveux
noirs
donc j'ai pas m'excuser de quoi que ce
soit je me marierai jamais à leur succès
sur les positions de chirac
c'est à dire non à la guerre et non à
ces deux guerres c'est à dire ses gains
alors cette guerre est illégal après
elle devient illégitime après ça devient
des forces d'occupation et après ça
devient un massacre c'est ça exactement
dont il faut une bande et 2005
il faut demander à un ramasseur alors
pourquoi si les mouches et excuse
convoqué berne devant le tribunal pénal
international que boucher galmiche
évident pour toi c'est ça c'est
exactement ce à quoi je vais faire cette
comparaison est pareil
c'est un scandale c'est un score 9 h en
train de me dire quand il ya eu au
kosovo quand il ya eu au kosovo et
heureusement qu'on est intervenue et
envahissement qu'on n'est pas passé par
la soul il entend vachement bien que
n'ayant 68 dans un jeu dit j'aime bien
mais bon c'est vrai il tente en laissant
temps quand on est contre la guerre
telle qu'elle a été faite telle qu'elle
a été fait la qualité on est fatalement
tout que saddam hussein ça l'amusé
surtout que
[Applaudissements]
ça fait j'aime pas ça c'est une parole
démocratique et voilà on sort on n'est
pas d'accord sur ce sujet là et donc on
se retrouve c'est bizarre je comprends
très bizarre que tu soutiennent pas et
tu comprennes pas qu'il y avait un
peuple irakien qui souffrait depuis 30
ans toute femme un bas-fond plus
maintenu sauf que moi je le sais d'elle
la preuve c'est qu'ils font des
manifestations c'est une manifestation
des matchs et annuler les pillages qui
s'est passé c'est que ce qui s'est passé
je suis un américain contre qui je n'ai
rien les malheureux sont là c'est des
jeunes d'à et on dit quand il ya eu des
cas justement on attaque les hôpitaux
les machins et que les que les médecins
peuvent les chirurgiens peuvent plus
travailler etc
ils disent nous on n'a pas d'ordre on
n'a pas de consignes pour protéger sa
équipe et protège effectivement le
pétrole et par qui partait parpaings pas
par des irakiens qui oui car c'est à
dire qu'un armement 30 ans de système
totalitaire d'horreurs absolues 30 ans
de dictature
et qu'est ce que ça a donné qu'est ce
que ça donnait une population
complètement acculturés qui va se manger
se manger surtout les abeilles aux
gallois mais qu'elles ne peuvent pas
supporter des dictatures jamais jamais
nous n'en parle d'avant de 89 avant la
chute du mur de berlin
j'en suis là je suis tenté de bien
supporter les colonels grecs qu'ils ont
supporté annonce écouter ils ont
supporté tous les dictateurs de la
planète pendant des heures voilà courir
compter société la coexistence pacifique
avec des armes de destruction massive
des deux côtés il s'appuyait sur le camp
dit démocratique contre les communistes
et contre toute possibilité que les
communistes cas du terrain donc il sait
des échanges je t'échange le chili
contre prague les autres faisaient des
horreurs à prague je t'échange de chivy
je t'échange le vietnam
contre quel tel diktat urgent et
échangent cuma contre tête c'était une
période de rush et je veux descendre
sont pas pour rien
non c'est d équilibre de la terreur où
l'on reparle dans 50 ans à 4 pozo
thierry alors en soit pas d'accord mais
que toi toi écoute le j'essaye de
diviser le plateau tu as raison c'est
bien je diviserai attention les gens
demandent s'il ya une cassette déjà pas
pour gagner bien sûr mais pour rendre
compte de l'horreur
ce que je voudrais pas moi ce que je
voudrais pas laurent et thierry c'est
boire ça veut tout dire à la dernière
fois
chirac changeantes d'un cap je voudrais
pas voir effectivement ça me serait
désagréable par rapport à la façon dont
vous êtes engagé sans arrêt dans cette
émission laurent et thierry en charge de
quatre maintenant
chirac dit et villepin c'est la consigne
put principe pragmatisme on va essayer
de faire en sorte que la libération du
peuple irakien se passe au mieux ce à
dire l'humanitaire remettre de l'eau
ouais c'est bien normal ce serait bien
de se dépêcher parce que les mecs ça
fait trois semaines qu'ils ont rien à
boire mais ils boivent l'eau des lolos -
séguin santander mais pas par les
américains qui sont capables à la guerre
avant lui jour on devient incapable de
leur mère deux jours 8 ans et tu te dis
jamais allé combien il reste préféré la
stabilité quand il y avait sa dame quand
il y avait l'électricité qui marchait
pour torturer les mecs quand il y à vélo
dans les baignoires
pour les enfants c'est qu'on pouvait
transporter la cie tranquillement et
dissoudre les corps c'est ça que tu
voulais non ce qu'on a ce qu'est ce
qu'ils ont changé les bombes américaines
sur la gueule dans les faubourgs de
bagdad mais tu rigoles et l'embargo à
lombia il n'y a eu dans toute la presse
lala alors des mesures que la couverture
partisane dans le papier dumont tous les
jours ne vous dit que la presse
française à minimiser lors de la
tyrannie bassiste oui enlisement c'est à
dire qu'à un moment donné il essaye
d'aller sur bagdad pour choper ce qu'ils
appelaient décapité assassiné à saddam
hussein et essayer de décapiter les
dirigeants qui sont une horreur une
camarilla de garde prétorienne mais on
est d'accord on est d'accord bien sûr on
essaye le premier homme va défendirent
où on ne sait pas en tout cas en tout
cas ça continue et là dessus qu'est ce
que fait la presse et qu'est ce que font
les journaux ils disent enlisement
pourquoi parce que les anglo américains
ont essayé de contourner les villes ne
pas faire tapis de bombes pas tapis de
bombes
comment 91 45
cours de préparation d'artillerie par
les avions pas tapis de bombes comme en
service 72 jours de bombardements
aériens avant de mettre un pied par
terre ils sont ils ont fait ils ont
lancé une bombe et le lendemain ils ont
avancé en contournant les villes en
risquant de se faire couper par les
arrières et là tout le monde avec un
petit sourire en disant ah [ __ ] ils
vont pas y arriver ils vont s'enliser et
les photos dans tous les journaux
c'était le bourbier c'était le vietnam
tout le monde a une espèce de jouissance
incroyable mais même tu connais le
suaire le saint suaire de turin et ben
là sur les pages du figaro
quand il y avait des experts militaires
qui s'exprimait où les experts
soviétiques ont formé armées irakiennes
mais on voyait des traces de sperme
tellement il jouissait en disant ils
vont se planter
ils vont se casser la gueule ils vont
pas y arriver arrivé à quoi à libérer le
peuple irakien mais tu sais ce que ça
veut dire le mot liberté est le peuple
irakien gildas qu'une envie tout ce
qu'on les turbans là bas ils n'ont
qu'une envie c'est de virer des séries
pas vrai son jab saut lui parfaitement
soir le parlait parlait par le peuple
kurde
tu as et un peu depuis dix ans e grâce à
l'excès à ce qu on appelle les zones
d'exclusion aérienne y vive la
démocratie
et quand les américains sont arrivés
c'est eux qui les ont sauvés déjà en 88
pensent que les chiites ils ont envie
dans le sud du pays de voir arriver les
américains avec à présent j'ai vu que
des mecs avaient des turbans clement
c'est vous le bras qu'on puisse dire
c'est ce qu'on a vu à la télé et ce qui
transparaît sait on veut pas des
américains en veut pas de forces
d'occupation et nous on veut l'islam est
ce que c'est le seul être comme l'iran
l'irak maintenant le sud de l'irak m
comme l'iran ce qu'ils on essaye de
faire comme le 60% de chiites en irak et
ben écoute et la démocratie chez les
chiites au pouvoir et ce qu'essayent ccm
- là c'est ce qu'essaye de faire les
mollahs le peuple irakien qui n'est pas
tous sous la coupe des mots large va
essayer de leur donner des moyens comme
au kosovo
exactement comme au kosovo de s'exprimer
ne ré apprendre à faire des journaux de
réapprendre à faire des des émissions de
télé à discuter le à s'engueuler
éventuellement à pas être torturé ou tué
si on a dit quelque chose
montre quelqu'un à un moment donné de ré
apprendre la démocratie des prétendants
et t'as pas envie d'aller avec une
caméra
par exemple en irak si j'ai envie de
rester ici de discuter avec toi discuter
avec fédérer
non mais j'étais avec eux c'est normal
vie comme ils sont quatre en fait
défendre les américains
j'espère du boulot dès mai à 14h géant
de crapaud à temps complet je suis
plutôt du côté des minorités donc c'est
bon je suis pas du tout convaincu par
les arguments
pas du tout c'est pas parce que je me
tais qui est qu'il a raison non mais il
dit par exemple romain enfin il dit avec
bruckner et de luxe man dans le monde
que l'anti-américanisme c'est le
nationalisme des imbéciles non mais
c'est ce qu'on risque ce qui est dit par
là c'est que ce que vous avez fait au
tout début d'émission
bush est un imbécile alors chirac ait pu
le grand con le grand menteur le facho
l'hérault est tous dans le sud qui
étaient dénoncés donc maintenant c'est
incroyable qui colle bien qu'à une
position ball yalaoui sur le coût de
l'exposition mondiale possession
pétainiste la verse lingerie là ce qui
se passe là restants dont ils ont
démissionné par rapport à juillet diana
rigg il est bien justifiée que gens qui
perdent pied chez guy robin tu vois tu
voulais être passé en guise
elles valent que lui
il revient 10 entendez il va interpréter
il revient maintenant on n'est pas
fâchés ils adorent discuter là bien sûr
sauf que là le problème est compliqué il
ya eu une telle désinformation en france
en dix ans on était dans le camp de la
paix alors qu'on ait fait on n'était pas
dans le camp de la paix on était dans le
camp de la honte de la collaboration
avec saddam hussein avec un assassin
avec un tueur avec un tueur de son
peuple
mais enfin quand même quels grands
catcheurs 2 millions personnes mais vous
savez ce que ça veut dire que ça va
évoluer a eu un comme ça on a dix en
profiter parce qu'ils sont jeunes de
leur expliquer le contraire modalités
quand quand saddam hussein s'est battu
contre l'iran tout le monde était bien
content qu'il arrête là l'islamisme
exacte et la guerre iran irak c'était 14
18 dans ce que je veux dire c'est que ça
on peut pas lui reprocher la guerre
contre l'iran puisque témoins étaient
ravis qu'il a fallu lancer la façon dont
il a traité la surcote simon déry même
je vais vous dire pire c'est à dire que
la france en 75 bâle 2 t saddam hussein
car les deuxièmes réserves de pétrole au
monde va le doter d'une industrie
nucléaire mais tout le monde est bidonné
tous les services de renseignement sont
bidonnés en 10 ans commence à la france
fournit un réacteur nucléaire à sanary
revient à l'environnement
c'est à dire c'est un jeu de rôle
moi j'ai un petit jet en plus et ben
bradshaw gentil sampler pour vous
l'impression que c'est une guerre elle
manque quand même un sacré bout de temps
oui alors c'est terrible pour toi te
faire traiter de pétainiste quand même
parce que c'est ce qu'il à dire j'aime
bien en main goupil mais je m'en fous de
ce qu'il dit de faire ces films n'ont
jamais dit que j étais pettini jeudi la
position de chirac était une position
pas du tout goal com il est là du togo
yens moi je reste un homme libre libre
de mots d'ordre libre et quand je pense
quelque chose fût ce avec le pen jeu oui
j'aime le vin rouge je crois que le pen
aime le vin rouge aussi il fait caca
tous les jours et mois pas autant que je
voudrais jamais pensé à le pen dit
jamais pensé et même à la limite si tu
si je pense à chirac
moi j'essaye de j'essaye d'être fidèle à
moi-même et d'une certaine manière c'est
donc très à la fois caricatural et est
assez pervers de vouloir dire que quand
on est contre cette guerre on soutient
un dictateur comme saddam hussein ça ça
pourrait nous révolter me mettre en
colère parce que c'est pas vrai c'est
partout comme moi c'est pas vrai c'est
pas vrai du tout je serai comme fou si
je devenais ça mais mais mais mais où
hélas le succès effectivement ils vont
donner le pouvoir à des à des
intégristes à des gens qui vont ça va
être les fous d'allah qui vont prendre
le pouvoir comme en iran je suis désolé
je suis d'accord avec la reddition
c'est là qu'on fait
hé hé et puis ils ont pas trouvées et
saddam hussein il s'est envolé mais ça
c'est parce qu'ils sont inspirés des oui
mais il a garé sa planète devant les
moyens parce que dans le dans le système
pétrole contre nourriture le fameux
embargo quand on voit ces palais quand
on voit ces robinetterie en or
effectivement il doit être en thalasso
quelque part j'espère que non mais c'est
surtout simplement sur la galice au kit
des arrière-pensées pétrolière dans
cette guerre que c'était simplement une
guerre de libération
tu ne mets pas effleuré par un tout
petit doute quand on connaît le palmarès
de duch est née de ce à quoi je préfère
je préfère que le pétrole soit aux mains
de la collection des anglais des
allemands des espagnols et tout plutôt
que de saddam hussein et le peuple
irakien et de l'arabie saoudite et qui
s'assoit le peuple irakien qu'en
profitent effectivement je prédis avec
les américains qu'ils soient consultés
par adamou scène qui va profiter du
plaisir azur bien sûr comme ça ça fait
rencontrer officiellement le dernier mot
chacun sa vérité comme disait puis un
des lots
[Musique]
je pensais
tout cela
voilà george bush votre ami romain
goupil préfère avoir lui comme ami que
sa famille mais c'est pas notre ami
saddam hussein non plus au revoir aux
mains à la semaine prochaine à la
semaine prochaine
c'est
ça
et
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus